Hôm qua anh khi tưởng nhật bản mới đây xa nhận tháng bây, năm 2020, là tháng bây nằm nhất từng được những nhận tại nước này trong 1 trăm 25 năm qua.
Như độ Trung Vinh, tuần quốc, cao hơn gần 2 phải chính độ xe sau với 1 Trung Vinh, ha mẹ đậm chốc.
Đặc biệt ngày bà 1 tháng bây, Như độ tại tình hiệu của đã liên tờ Bùng Mốt phải 2 độ xe, mất cảo nhất lịch sử tại nhật bản.
Tình trạng nằm nghiêm trong tế tục đại giữa à các khu vực biệt bác và biệt tầy trong tháng tâm.
Nạn lông ai hơn 1 mua năm nay ký thuộc sớm hơn 3 tuần ở miệng tây nhận, cao theo lượng 1 thấp hơn nhiều sợ với thông thường.
Giới trước, phải kêu gọi người dân tiếp kiệm nước ở những nơi khu hà,
câu quan khi tưởng cùng cảnh bảo tháng tâm vẫn sẽ khắc nghiệp với như đột nạn nóng kêu dài và thậm chí có thể lập những kỳ lục như độ mấy.
Người dân được quên gạo theo dõi cảnh bảo xe nắng và chủ đọc bảo vệ sự khỏe.
Bình đôi khí hậu và hẹn tượng nống lưỡng tần câu cũng đang gọi bình đôi sâu sắc hẹn thống xin tháng nhất bàn.
Hẹn nhiều cây hoa anh đào, nở sớm, bất thường, phóc, không thể nở lượng mua.